Catherine is next in Tennessee hi
Catherine
how do you do hey Dave and dr. Dee's I'm
a mid 30 year old nurse practitioner
trying to navigate the online dating
world in the midst of a pandemic what
advice would you give see if the person
I'm dating has a career that just
doesn't sit well with me
some examples are like whole life
insurance agents or mortgage life
insurance agents timeshare agents you
know debt collectors telemarketers or
those who practice left-handed puppetry
I thought you were gonna say drug dealer
or dancers mommy sells cocaine me
doesn't sell whole life insurance but
they're so nice hey this is how it
starts Kath I'm just kidding
that's how it starts all right so I
think I think you're the first thing
that you did that's really wise is to
call two completely out of touch old
married guys to help you navigate online
dating this was a huge well done there
that's big-time the second thing is I'll
tell you in all seriousness is this just
is it it sounds funny and kind of get
out out till I feel a little bit but it
just goes back to values what are your
values and write them down and hold fast
to them and dad don't budge on them if
you're not gonna buy a whole life
insurance and you don't do whole life
insurance and you think people who
peddling that or preying on people
you're gonna have a hard time being a
relationship with somebody you've got to
respect who they are and what they do my
I married a teacher and I I was able to
honor her every day and so that that's
my take on it if I agree with John I'm
not sure we have the answer but the
you know I I don't know that on first
blush anything you named there would be
a complete deal-killer by that I mean
maybe they're about to leave that career
or maybe they've got plans to do it for
a little while longer
or maybe they hate every day and they're
looking for or you know in other words
maybe it is not an indicator of their
character but if you get in there and
you associate those things with scummy
people and you determine yeah this is a
scummy person obviously you would walk
away real quickly but I'm not sure that
it just says okay they're based on their
career I'm not gonna check the box on
online dating I would just X that one
out I can no matter what all people that
do X or Y or Z I'm not going to talk to
any of them I would talk to them and I
mean but after a couple dates if you
could become convinced that really they
are smarmy then obviously you're going
to walk away but you might find a real
story in there if somebody who's in the
middle of some kind of journey or
transformation that you wouldn't mind
going on the ride with if all the other
things lined up okay it's a guilt that
gets me if it's it's it's so I shouldn't
feel guilty if I feel like it's not
right no no your values you your values
no I mean let's just do you know you
know why would you feel guilty if you
didn't want a drug a code date a cocaine
dealer you wouldn't feel guilty that's
an extreme example that you're still
making the decision based on values
right but it's an extreme example that
allows us to laugh and but it
illustrates that I used a value-based
decision someone who doesn't mind
cocaine and who does a lot of cocaine
might think you'd be cool today to
cocaine deal that'd be great you know my
supplier you know but the but you know
I'm saying it's a the the thing is it's
your value system and your we use our
values to make decisions every day
whether we even are conscious that we
have values you still make decisions on
that all the time you make decisions on
how you're going to treat someone you
make decisions on type of things you're
going to buy or do all of it it ends up
being
those kinds of things so yeah I mean I
think you're wise to do that no far from
feeling guilty what I wouldn't do is
just say 100% of the people that
currently work at this moment in the
whole life industry 100% of the people
that work currently in the debt
collector business are disqualified you
can say you got one big strike against
you bubble you might even have two
strikes coming out of the gate and you
only got one more right and so if you
get into the conversation the first day
you go yep I thought so you're out of
here
but something you said is so why's this
I'd rather see somebody's default
settings set to let's talk to somebody
let's engage with humanity yeah there's
yeah I think going with preconceived
notions just burns holes through people
a lot so have your values and and hold
them so I look at like deciding I'm
never gonna work or someone based on one
tweet yeah you know how astronaut that's
just silly yeah you have no concept of
what you're talking about you've no
window into their life you wouldn't it's
too thin all right it's too thin
which makes you narrow right I always
win it when a when somebody's a
telemarketer calls me I always want to
exhale a little bit with the frustration
that somebody just called me in the
middle of a meeting and I thought there
was an emergency but then the second
thing is this person is probably doing
the best they can to get a job and
trying to make ends meet for their
family and I want to honor that my
friend up here for them was a person you
are too kind
I want a high five them and then I'm
gonna hang up the phone with dignity and
we're kindness so yeah I'm just gonna
hang up the phone